this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by upstart keeps coors pure and
expressvpn
more on that later let's get into the do
the honeydew
with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it
in the night pants studios i'm ryan
sickler ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on
all social media i want to make sure i
tell you about my tour dates now listen
to this intro because there's more info
in here
that you're really going to like and
you're really going to want to be a part
of all right
uh tour dates september 16th through the
18th
i'm in phoenix at the house of comedy
september 30th to
october 2nd i'll be at helium in indy
i'm doing vegas with tom segura october
8th and 9th i'll be headlining the brea
improv
october 28th more dates are coming we're
putting them on the books go to
ryansickler.com join the email list
you'll be among the first to know new
dates
uh the website for this show is the
honeydewpodcast.com
and please make sure you subscribe to
the youtube channel people ask me all
the time how can we help how can we help
subscribe to youtube it's free you're
watching it anyway hit subscribe means
nothing to you means everything to us
it's super important um and the patreon
the patreon is the honeydew with you all
if you or someone you know has that
story it has to be heard please submit
it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com this community is growing
and growing i mean the stories are just
they're not stopping they're not
stopping
um and i'm not stopping so if you're in
for the long haul sign up for a year
you'll get over a month free
um we're now giving you the honeydew uh
ad free
a day early at no additional cost you
get the entire back catalog
of the honeydew with you all plus new
shows five bucks a month all right um
also want to let you guys know now that
ringtones of my laugh
are finally available for you people
who've been asking me for a decade
okay go to itunes go anywhere you get
ringtones
ringtones of my laugh are available in
the itunes store
you just have to go search my name
scroll down to ringtones
hit it they're there or just go to
ryansickler.com there's a link that can
take you out there all right
you guys have been seeing these d1
athletes that have now allowed the
scumbag ncaa
double a's allow the sponsor now
or these kids are allowed to make money
and everybody's out there sponsoring
these d1 kids well
this ain't d1 over here this the
honeydew okay
i want some honeydew athletes i'll
sponsor you i'll throw you some merch
go wear my [__] out there where you are
i already got three on board right now
okay
i got a guy named marcus everett who's a
bowfisherman and this dude is a straight
[__] killer
i got kaden wood who's a d2 pitcher at
seton hill went to the college world
championship this year
i got a young surfer named beck adler
who's one of the top
uh surfers in his age range right now in
the world so
uh you got to be good i'm not just
taking any [__] [__] out there
drinking
beers and throwing corn hole give me a
give me a bowler
give me a guy that throws darts give me
a frisbee golfer but you got to be good
you got to be good and you can't be d1
that's the other thing i'll sponsor a d1
player i will
but i want you d2s and jucos and [__]
all right
um that's the news that's everything
also
no no no this is a very important
announcement actually very important
announcement
my man ash the backbone of this show is
moving to
uh austin almost in nashville with
everybody else
going with the ymh crew so i'm looking
for people that want to help i'm looking
for people who are fans of the show
that know what is going on here and
that's what i'm looking for i do not
need marketing
or audio mixing i'm looking for video
and
editing production all right so if
you're interested and you think you have
the skills and you want to help and you
live local
then hit me up all right hit
honeydewpodcast gmail.com just put you
know
honeydew work or something like that in
the subject line all right now
that that's all out of the way you know
what we do over here we highlight the
low lights
and uh this guy's one of my favorite
[__] lowlights it's not his first
rodeo here on the do y'all
please welcome back to the honeydew joey
diaz everybody welcome back to the
honeydew
what's happening brother it's so good to
see you man you look good you really do
look good you got a little your son
kissed there you out there with the
family in the in the summer jersey sun
[__] tremendous girly is tremendous i
go to this
i go to this city pool like it's like a
pool for the
for the town you got to see this [__]
place
i mean basketball court yeah you were
telling me baseball court
[__] three pools slides for the kids
great food so like when i finish up here
with you
i'll shoot over there and run in the
pool for a while
cool off and i'm out of there by 3 30.
they have an old man section it's
perfect
they got [__] you know it's it's it's
kids up to like 11.
yeah and then it just drops off to old
people because
if you're 15 and over you go down to
shore yeah you're not [__] around
you know no so i'm good at the [__]
pool the shore is a [__] madhouse
yeah but i'm good at the [__] pool
how are you doing
i'm good man everything is great i can't
complain at all
i'm healthy things are going well i got
you back
and uh speaking of summer we're picking
up in june
of 1990 what wait what year did we
started what year did we actually start
your birth year is what
when were you born who the [__] no 63
we're only 30 couple years in
we're only in 1995 i love it all right
so
june of 95 is where uh we pick up you
had just talked about
i think you just had your daughter right
or no no you
no not 90. no your go ahead you take it
june of 95 was when i decided that
my relationship with my daughter wasn't
going to work
i had gone up to detroit to do joey's
comedy club and i met a girl
i had been uh without a girlfriend
for a long time i was just having little
affairs and stuff
and i met a girl in michigan and uh
she came to visit me in boulder right
after that
and we hit it off and she was moving to
seattle
so from boulder she went to seattle
like in the beginning of june and i
thought about what was going on in my
life at the time
you know and my wife hooked up
with a husband and you know they were
trying to start a family and
i wanted to be a comedian really bad and
i i had my job
at the sports betting service so i said
you know what
let me go on the road let me pack my
[__] in storage
give up this apartment there's no reason
for me to pay
for this apartment and let me um
go to seattle for the summer okay so
this is how you ended up getting up to
seattle okay
yeah because i know about your seattle
days i didn't know it went for okay
go ahead so so it was like uh
june 25th of 1995.
i can't believe i mean [__] day i was
[__] heartbroken
like i was heartbroken because deep down
i knew
i wasn't coming back like i i just said
to myself
i'm gonna come back in september and
make i planned on making like a 100
grand
from september to january with the
sports betting service
so i was like i got that job but i
really want to be a [__] comic
you know this thing with my daughter is
not gonna work
the way i wanted to let me
go out there and find who the [__] i am
and find some success and then i'll come
back and be a father
that was my plan you know okay so i
loaded up my car
i had a uh a boxing
b210 that i bought that's what it was
[__] dachshund i'm driving a
dachshund in 95.
a b210 i know that [__] exactly
[__] car was tougher than that i
couldn't get rid of that car
yeah i ended up getting pulled
up that's how it went out he just got
they just pulled it out for you
oh let me tell you something the [__]
the side panel fell off
at the end the side panel was off the
brakes were
i mean that car did me i think i paid
800 for that car
i drove that car from from colorado to
michigan and baltimore probably ten
times
each place i went they're just a little
long
if you take care of them they're little
lawn mowers they'll run forever
it was a [__] beast that car i owe
that car
my life i saw stanhope and i did the
same thing i put a hanger in the back
seat
i put everything in the trunk from a
frisbee to boxing gloves
everything you know so i could swim
goggles
i brought a suit you know and i said let
me do this [__] triple run
which will get me up to oregon and then
i'll go to seattle
i'll get to seattle by saturday night so
i'll never forget leaving uh
boulder and headed to ogden utah that
was my official first
one nighter out of boulder is that right
didn't use that
and that's your first headlining hour uh
out of
colorado no i wasn't in the headline
i was i was featuring for tribble at the
time okay
i was doing triple runs i wasn't
featuring at clubs i was them singing at
clubs
there was no feature work in my life i
was dying to be a feature
i had about 25 minutes i was dying to
feature but nobody would feature me
so triple featured me i think it's 75
hours of [__] night
you know and i i did wednesday
yeah i went to [__] ogden
some spots on wyoming and then the last
night was lagrange oregon
and that day i realized that i was just
i don't know
how many hours from seattle so i pretty
much
finished my [__] gig and i just shot
to seattle on saturday night
and she stripped so i met her at she
left the key under the [__] thing for
me and i waited for the apartment
i got there about 1 30 she got home
about 2
30. i still remember being with her that
night
and waking up sunday and the first thing
we did was go down to the comedy
underground
and it was closed but i didn't give a
[__] i just wanted to touch the building
yeah
i had heard so many great things about
that club
i was like [__] this i'm just gonna
[__] go down there and touch the
building they had a number on the wall
and i called it nobody answered you know
it was a [__] nightmare but i didn't
give a [__]
i just wanted to be in [__] seattle
and
do comedy that was it you know that was
all that was on my mind
i'm just putting this phone on airplane
mode so nobody [__] bothers
there you go [__]
these talk suckers love to bother me
when something good goes on when i'm
sitting here
not doing nothing nobody calls nothing i
know nobody yeah
once you're doing something everybody
wants to call you back that's why today
i didn't call nobody in the morning
because if they don't answer then they
call you back exactly when you're doing
a [__] podcast so
i got up this morning i shipped 418 mugs
for patreon damn all right and then i
went to the [__] gym
finished up my workout week and got back
so back to 95
so i'm living in seattle and that i'll
never forget that that monday was the
open mic
and i ran down there and signed up
i think i was like number two and that
night
all of a sudden a kid walked in with a
backwards hat on
and a boston red sox had a long hair
yeah i know who that dick is
and it was and it was josh yeah yeah
and you know he went on stage he was
well known there
i went up to him i you know you're from
boston i'm from jersey you know
we started talking he probably thought i
was [__] weird
you know he was looking at me like what
the [__]
and uh i chased him down for like three
[__] days like
he told me where he worked at lobo loco
and all this [__] and i'm like [__] it
i gotta hook up with you you gotta make
this help me out you know
and uh it was funny because i got to
seattle
i went to that open mic that monday and
i got a bunch of numbers from people
like who to call for bookings and [__]
and i started calling people and
everybody called back
like i got there on saturday
night i went on stage monday
and by wednesday i already had a gig for
the weekend i was playing
moscow idaho with vince valenzuela
great [__] guy he's in la i think
he's not doing comedy anymore i don't
know what he's doing
but that was my first weekend moscow
idaho as a [__] feature act
but john fox i'm like wait a second
things are moving fast
i got in with uh the chick from oregon
that was booking donna richards
i got in with another chick who was josh
wolfe's manager
she had a bunch of rooms i was in with
tribble
and i was doing spots at the [__]
underground which was
just a tremendous club you know
yeah so i i was in seattle
maybe two weeks and i was already
rocking
like i you know in boulder i would do
like
five sets a week and i had to drive all
over the [__] world
in colorado i had to go to wyoming and
[__]
in seattle we had two spots on a monday
night
four spots on a tuesday six spots on a
wednesday there was a spot on thursday
you know
there was always something it was just
[__] mind-boggling
and i'm having a great time with the
broad you know
she's stripping at night i'm helping a
count of money
i'm taking 20 20 from me 25
i'm dropping 100 bills on the floor and
stepping on them
[__] hysterical [__] hysterical
she was great
you know we still talk her and i still
do that's
you know what let me say this because
again i want to step out of this because
i'm
not just a comedian i'm still a fan i'm
a fan
of comedy i'm a student of the game and
i'm a fan of yours obviously and what i
love
for me what i love hearing is
that you know you forget that these
these people like you
and and you know they started somewhere
and to hear your excitement
about i know exactly what you mean i
don't give a [__] if it's sunday at one
o'clock and this building's closed
there's energy coming off that [__]
building
i want to go be around it touch it i
don't care if it's got the gates on it i
want to peek in the window i want to
know
and then you go the next night you run
there and you're number two
on the list or very early because
you want to [__] like i love hearing
that
that's what i love that young joey did
you know that's where it started
and there you are now you've you've left
this thing what people don't realize
i think a lot of people don't just don't
think about it if they're not in this
world but
this job we do it's selfish
it's a selfish thing i'm not saying that
in a negative way but
the definition of so it's we have left
our families we have left
friends we have left our homes we've
left everything
in search of something that just we
ourselves want to do
and fulfill for ourselves and that's a
very selfish act
and then once you get into this motley
crew of [__]
people in comedy rarely do we really get
to hang out
unless we have a gig in town on the same
night at the same time in the same venue
some nights i see you we we
give each other a little love because
i'm doing the 10 you already did the
eight
we don't get to kick it maybe at a
festival something like that it's almost
it's a solo sport
comedy's a soul it's like tennis it's
you out there so i
love hearing that you were stoked just
to be
out there in the building and this is
like your real this is your real
starting comedy right here in 1995.
it was fun it was really it was really
when i think about it it was a lot of
[__] fun like i was just having
i was probably making 800 a month you
know
but who gave a [__] right and then back
then you're not thinking about agents or
where
you know you're just trying to get your
feet under you your legs and build this
[__]
routine that that can hopefully carry
you and then you can build
other places so you're also getting
those triple runs you're probably
building material pretty quickly you had
a lot of spots
yeah i was it was uh i was a student of
the game
you know i didn't my only i had rent
my nuts were rent child support and my
pager
that was it i wasn't paying any bills
there was no credit cards
i didn't have anything i was very hand
to mouth
it was very old school but i didn't give
a [__] i was living it
i was in it when you're in it like that
you don't give a [__]
you don't even see anything else and
i'll never forget that
you know this girl was a sweetheart
but she stripped there were some things
i couldn't deal with
you know there was a lot of things when
you date a stripper you have to be a
strong type of dude and i wasn't strong
for that
you know i would go to pick her up and
my heart would break you know
so i was actually thinking of coming
back
like i called the sports betting thing
in mid-august and i said hey can i come
back and they're like absolutely
when do you want to come back and i go
how about like
[__] september 8th or something it
was some date
and uh they go yeah we'll see you then
and i was all set to go
and i hung up the phone and all of a
sudden john fox calls me
and he goes what are you doing labor day
weekend
and i go nothing i was supposed to leave
that weekend
yeah september [__] crazy that is i
was supposed to leave that weekend and
he goes i have a weekend for you as a
feature
this is my first feature spot in a club
never mind it being the [__]
underground now i could talk some [__]
i was opening up for laurie kilmartin
yeah i did
i just saw her at the improv the other
night yeah i love i love her i think
she's great
i love lauren me too lori was a pro
yep already in 95. wow okay
not you can't take anything away from
laura i just followed her
improv yeah she is she's stronger than
death
so she was i was so stoked
you know and i put it in god's hands i
was like if god wants me to be a feature
act
and i'm here [__] it it doesn't look
like i'm going back
to colorado you know it just doesn't
look like i'm going back to colorado
so it was uh we had a great summer
her and i were [__] nuts like we
would just do
the craziest [__] things you know and
i got to start hanging around with josh
and brody stevens and tana manu and
gavin
there was just this crew that i had fit
into
i had that in colorado but i really
didn't those guys started
uh the reason why i left colorado is
because those guys started
back biting me yeah like those open
microstarted talking behind my back and
they're the ones
one of the guys in denver was the guy
who got me thrown out of the comedy
works
so i was kind of like i don't want to
really really be a part of comedy clicks
but those guys were a great crew let's
take a quick break and tell you about
our first sponsor upstart
so many americans experienced financial
hardship in the last year and upstart
can help you
regain your footing and get things back
on track
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan
all online so whether you're paying off
credit cards or you're consolidating
high interest debt or you're funding
personal expenses
over half million people have used
upstart to get one
fixed monthly payment i know you guys
are using it because they keep coming
back and you guys keep hitting me up
being like damn i got a good deal
and it's really helped me out i wish i
had something like this back in the day
i just did consolidations and
paid interest out the butt but upstart
knows more
than just your credit score and it's
expanding access to affordable credit
so unlike other lenders upstart
considers your income and current
employment to find you a smarter rate
for your loan with a five minute online
rate check you can see your rate
up front for loans between one thousand
to fifty thousand dollars and you can
receive funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com honeydew
that's upstart.com
honeydew don't forget to use my url to
let them know i sent you
all right loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com
honeydew our next sponsor is keeps as
guys
so much of our identity is wrapped up in
our hair from how it feels after getting
a fresh cut
to the way it's perfectly styled before
going out that's why
when we get in our 20s and 30s and start
noticing the first signs of hair loss it
definitely feels like panic time
because let's face it no guy is ever
ready to go bald
thankfully now there's keeps the simple
and easy way to keep your hair
did you know two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair left get treated from home you
used to have to go to the doctor's
office for your hair loss prescription
but now thanks to keeps you can visit a
doctor online and get hair loss
medication
delivered right to your home they make
it easy and they deliver your medication
every three months so you can say
goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines
and awkward doctor visits okay if you're
ready to take action
and prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
honeydew to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s dot
com
slash honeydew now let's get back to the
duke you know that whole crew was a
great crew
i missed my uh daughter
so i took a ride back to boulder
with the stripper we drove back to
colorado like in mid-september
to get my stuff out of storage and all
that [__]
and my ex-wife let me see my daughter
which was [__] rare
yeah you know i still have the picture
from that day you know that's
it's in my wallet and uh that was one of
the last times i basically i think i saw
it two times after that
over the years and then uh we went back
to boulder we saw my daughter
we brought my [__] back and then
something happened that
was [__] like was not in my cards
i didn't even see it coming i had heard
about the san francisco comedy
competition
and the seattle comedy competition i had
heard about these things
and i never knew i would be good enough
to perform at one of them you know what
i'm saying i'm like i'm not
i'm not going to be good enough and one
day ron reed came up to me
and he goes are you doing the contest i
go i don't know
am i good enough to do the contest he's
like well we're having auditions just
get your six minutes ready
and i went down there i auditioned and a
couple weeks ago they got back to me and
said you made the contest
i was like are you [__] kidding me it
was like me
josh wolfe aisha taylor yeah tyler yeah
um a comic african-american kid that was
funny as [__]
he passed about two years ago uh
floyd floyd floyd and he had a
he used to go to uh what's that [__]
were you missing a kidney
dialysis yeah so i used to call him
floyd the kidney
he used to live in portland oregon
he was from michigan god rest his soul
[__] great kid
funny as [__] you know and in your mind
you look at the
the festival and i'm like well there's
josh wolfe there's brody there's tayna
i didn't know brody went up to seattle i
didn't know he was up there
bro that's why that's where i met him so
i had in my mind i'm like i'm gonna do
really good at this thing
and i remember going on stage the first
night of the contest at a pizza parlor
and i [__] took like 13th place
out of 15 people i thought i was gonna
[__] die
i'm surprised to hear that i went home
and i cried
and i looked at my set and i [__]
revamped my
set i kicked it up i was up all [__]
night
putting the [__] where they belong in
the lab
oh i was [__] pissed i'm like i can't
[__] do 13th place
and then that tuesday night i redeemed
myself
that tuesday night i came in like fifth
and then wednesday i came in like fourth
yeah and then friday i came in like
sixth
and saturday i came in like fourth so i
made the semi-fucking finals
i'm like holy [__] and everybody kept
telling me you're not gonna make this
anything because they don't like dirty
comments you're not gonna do well so i
said okay
so you have a week off and then you go
back again
and i went back to the semi-finals and
again it was a nightmare
but then it was great it was a great
experience there was this kid named
james inman do you know that is have you
ever heard of james inman i haven't no
james inman his goal was to stay sober
one of the funniest guys you'll ever
work with
one of the funniest guys you'll ever see
that didn't become a superstar
he was very funny very bill hickish
very honest game and
uh the secret to knock him off his game
was to give him boots
okay okay so yeah so he wasn't drinking
like he was crazy one night he came in
he was stabbed
his wife stabbed him he came in like
freshly stabbed
yeah from a to an open mic he was
bleeding i mean
this crew was crazy we had a coke dealer
upstairs
because the comedy underground is
downstairs
it used to be in a bar called swanees
okay
and downstairs was the underground so
there was a coke dealer upstairs i mean
it was great so what we did was you gave
james inman
tequila shots even though he wasn't
drinking you had the waitress bring him
tequila
and he would drink him and then he would
start going off on comics
and it was classic he went up to uh i
forget this comic's name
he does a lot of spots at burbank and a
lot of corporates now
he never really made it in the comedy
world he did great in the corporate
world
and uh he's a clean comic i'll never
forget one night inman grabbed him and
told him if you do another joke about
your [__] wife
up on stage i'll [__] kill you so we
would send them over
to the people so he would drink tequila
and snap like that
and snap like a twig and he'd go off on
other comics and knock him out of that
game
so you're
because when you're a comic and you do
those contests yeah you got to learn how
to piss on some of these legs
you piss on somebody's leg too hard you
might crack yourself
i'm saying
[Laughter]
oh my god oh my god
sorry all right i cried you know we we
[__] did
he's drinking yelling at everybody he's
yelling everybody and guess what i
[__] did great with the semi-finals
and i'll never forget that we ended the
semi-final week
it was supposed to end on a sunday night
and we'd know
who was gonna make it to the top five
david crow won it that year mitch
hedberg was in it
yeah it was it was craziness
so uh that sunday i'll never forget
somebody gave his tickets to the seattle
seahawk game and like 12 comedians
we all floyd j phillips okay was his
name god bless his soul
paina me brody josh gavin
uh floyd a bunch of us i think aisha
tyler
we all went to a seahawk game and we had
such a great time and then we went to
mccormick and schmitz yeah had a two
dollar menu
the two dollar menu a cheeseburger for
two dollars and order fries for two
dollars
clams on a hat shell two dollars it was
[__] great
so we uh we did that
and then i made it to sixth place that
night
has a dirty comic i didn't make it to
the finals
but i took a six to here with aisha
taylor david crowe
mitch hedberg and it was it was
[__] great i mean everything was
great my future was looking great
when you do good in the seattle contest
people from the area stop start hiring
you harvey's called
you know the improv there was a an
improv up in seattle
oh i didn't know that yeah
in yet or how far away are we now in
your comedy
i i started in 91 in seattle i mean i'm
talking about
just the next seattle scene in seattle i
was dead about
six months and all this is popping that
fast huh
popping that that's really fast you know
that looking back how fast that is yeah
it was fast and then that thanksgiving
they always had that show on wednesday
night you know that big show on
wednesday that's the biggest bar night
of the year
man thanksgiving so what we did was what
we used to do was
we me and josh kanan brody a bunch of us
would book out wednesday nights
and they gave you 65 of the door
so i don't know whose night it was on
the night before thanksgiving but this
is going to blow your mind
i'm up on stage the night before
thanksgiving
and i get off the stage and there's a
guy waiting for me
and he goes hey bro listen
i'm doing a pilot
and uh in uh
l.a for cbs and you're [__]
perfect for it i'll be in touch
and then as i was walking away from him
another guy came up to me and he goes
you'd be perfect for the latino laugh
god damn dude on show time
we'd love for you to audition in january
maybe send the tape
we'll fly you to la i was like wow
things are really [__] happening
and then i got a feature spot uh
december something at the [__]
underground and i was opening up for
this comic from chicago
and it's friday night we're all down
there
and i'm about to go up on stage and that
was the beginning of my bad luck
waiting to go up the mc is up and when
the mc hit the stage
two four guys came in three guys came in
i'm talking to the manager these three
guys come in they pay
and they're chatty and they sit down and
i
i'm still talking to the manager he hits
him then he comes back and we're still
bullshitting
and finally he goes these [__] guys
and he goes over
and he tells the three guys guys if you
want to talk you could have stayed
upstairs
and they're like all right we'll get our
money back and they follow ron
to the [__] table ron gives him back
the 10 bucks or 15 bucks whatever it was
to get in
and the one guy goes thanks and he
smacks ryan whoa ron's a 55 year old
[__] man
these kids are kids you know they're
like 20s so i'm standing there with like
three other comics i don't know who the
[__] they were
and nobody did nothing so i jumped the
[__] one guy you know what yeah
[__] yeah i jumped him and i pushed the
other guy and now
we're going at it you need those spots
joe you need these spots
no you're about to solidify yourself
enough yeah
and ron reed's a good guy and [__]
so i [__] go off you know and thank
god there was a puerto rican
guy from the bronx upstairs he was a cop
a seattle cop a city cop he came down
with his uniform on
and he pulled me off the guys and i went
and reached for his gun
while he was holding me i loosened the
holster he's like what are you doing
i'm like let's let's shoot these
[__] you know and he's like
you're crazy
so they pull us apart
he said let's let's let's shoot me
and you shoot i was [__] i was born i
was
i was out of my mind sickler so
uh i go up on stage my shirt is ripped
like the one guy grabbed it over here
and it was ripped and it was like
falling over
and i'm sweating and i defeat the emcee
brought me up
fresh from the fight and i go up on
stage
in the fight they [__] know i got
into a fight they heard the commotion
and they're like you know
what's going on i'm telling these street
[__] guys
[__] them i'm the king of swing i'm
talking all this nonsense
and finally the bar gets surrounded by
cops
i could see the cops all
around the [__] bar waiting on me
bicycle cops
all these cops in seattle the
underground was downstairs
so it rains a lot in seattle yeah so
it's
it's really [__] humid so [__]
this is something that i'll never forget
when you're waiting to go up at the
underground
there's a beam there's a beam that you
stand by
and there's a table where people sit
right there
and i'll never forget how many nights i
would look at the table
and people would be eating nachos and
there'd be big water bugs
on their nachos no because it was the
basement
yeah and they had those big
[__] puerto rican water bugs the ones
that you see in the bronx
with the [__] tentacles you [__] yeah
oh my god they're huge
people would beat nachos not looking at
the nachos
and there'd be a [__] roach on the
nachos
jesus christ it was such a [__]
whack-a-doo club at the time
but every time you stood by that beam if
you looked at people's visions
you'd see a roach on one of the dishes
and nobody would ever say anything
about the roaches it was [__]
terrible
i remember one night going up on stage
and seeing a roach on some guy's leg
like one of those water bugs and he just
shot up in the [__] air
you know so i get off stage the cops
ask me a bunch of [__] questions
and uh they let me go
right now are they are they questioning
you because you tried to unholster the
the peace
or just because of everything you know
the puerto rican cop didn't wrap me up
okay they're they're questioning me
about the fight and what happened
and what the details were and blah blah
blah blah blah
okay they let me go the next day i get
up
and uh i'm living in the u district with
my girlfriend
and there was a [__] taco place and
they made potato tacos
for 50 cents a piece when you were broke
comic
[__] you know so i would go there and
get like eight four dollars worth of
tacos which
is eight tacos and that would be my
thing i'm walking
the next day to the taco place and i'm
not thinking about nothing you know
i see that there's no cars and i [__]
across the street
and i get to the other side and next
thing you know two bicycle cops come up
to me
and they're like excuse me sir do you
know what you just did
and i go yeah i crossed the street and
they're like no you jaywalk
you [__] jaywalk i'm like what are
you talking about he goes you jaywalk
i'm like no i didn't and they go listen
we got to give you a ticket
i'm like this ain't [__] happening
this isn't [__] happening
and like yes it is you're getting a
[__] ticket
and i go well good luck you know i'm
going to la to [__]
i'm going to la to shoot a [__] cbs
pilot [__]
you know they gave me the ticket and i
looked at it and i go this is what i
think
i just ripped it down and i throw it
away
right i don't think nothing of it i go
get my [__] tacos i forget all about
it
about two weeks later i'm downstairs
minding my own [__] business and
my girlfriend comes home and she goes i
gotta go to the bathroom really bad
can you stand here with the car and i go
yes
i don't know i don't know what the [__]
happened i don't know what
it was she
yells down it's gonna i got stay down
there
i got a call something happened
and her and i got into an argument from
the downstairs
to the window i'm like you better hurry
the [__] up i gotta whatever
she's like i'll take my sweet pond just
give me 10 minutes or whatever she
yelled back
do you know that the [__] cops came
for that i'm standing outside she's
upstairs
oh they came because you guys are
yelling too
to each other and i mean people walking
on the street nobody said nothing
and all of a sudden a cop pulls up and
he arrest me for [__] harassment
yes so that's my first [__] arrest
i get broke i mean i'm brought to the
station and everything
i'm like this is [__] embarrassing
say something to them and they're like
we can't say
she's like i can't do nothing the cops
like he can't do nothing
you know you you were yelling somebody
[__] wants to press charges
i'm like what the [__] kind of [__] is
this so wait so
it's not your girlfriend who wants to
press charges you're telling me no
you're telling me that if i'm an upset
karen
i can just be like there's a guy next
door and i can press charges
yeah i don't know what that's crazy [__]
that this was
it was just really [__] yeah it was
like misdemeanor harassment
so i get out i don't think nothing of it
i got a court date and about a week
later
i'm sleeping and there's a knock on the
door
it's two cops when i open up the door i
go what's going on
and they're like jose diaz yeah step
aside
you're under arrest for failure to
appear you were supposed to be in court
yesterday
that [__] went from a ticket to an
arrest
[Laughter]
you're the only [__] i know on
the planet that's been arrested for
jaywalk and i got plenty of friends that
got tickets
and while i'm arrested for jaywalking
they're like you were just here for
[__] harassment
they're like there's a [__] problem
or some [__]
so then guess what happens i go back to
[__]
answer the charges for harassment
and what the [__] do you think happens
they press charges on me for the fight
at the bar i don't know
oh come on that's coming back
now that comes back to bite me in the
ass and i get
charged with assault how's that not
and [__] uh they wanted to get me on
a felony assault
even though it was self-defense the
whole thing that's what i'm saying how
is it not this guy is over here getting
beat
so they [__] put me on
probation and made me go to anger
management what's that like what tell me
what
what do you where do you go what the
[__] do you sit through and listen it
was a [__] it was
it was just me and six other people
two women six guys were in there too huh
yeah okay yeah like the one chick
punched the boyfriend in the face
and the other chick stabbed somebody a
mailman or something i don't know
yeah i'm sitting there just getting worn
out you know
just getting worn out and i did it for
about three months i actually
went and then and it helped out a little
bit
so is it is it once a week is that what
it is weekly for three months
like once a week it's like once a week
or something
so now i'm involved with that but i want
to make money
you know i needed to make money like i
go you know i got a lot of dead time in
the daytime
let me get a job selling cars and
i get to drive one of their new cars
instead of driving my [__] nissan
around this [__]
center whatever this [__] b210 is
dodging
so i get a job at [__] uh
like a honda place in everett
in everett close to seattle okay
they give me a job and they give me a
car to drive i'm loving life i'm driving
a new honda
i'm doing comedy with a shirt and a tie
on you know
where are you really i'm loving life
yeah i would go right from the
dealership right now that makes sense
to the open mic you know and i would do
whatever the [__] they had
and sure enough i get pulled over
one night i get pulled over because the
cop says i
read a red light now another red light a
stop sign one thing about me is i
stopped bullying for stop signs and [__]
i stop for the [__] stop sign i i
go and austin the cop comes out of no
way pulls me over
it's like 10 o'clock on a friday night
okay
he pulls me over he goes you ran the
stop
sign blah blah blah blah i tell him i
didn't but i stopped he goes all right
no worries let me just get your
information
he comes back he goes mr diaz get out of
the car oh jesus christ
you're driving a stolen car
they gave you a stolen car
jesus christ
i can't even
so they kept me in jail from friday to
sunday oh
man for possession of a stolen car
and i'm telling them that the dealership
gave it to me they
won't call the dealership because the
thing they finally monday
i call the dealership from the [__]
jail cell
and they're like let's check it out i go
i can't come in to work cause i'm in
jail because you guys
reported a stolen car and they're like
it's a mistake
let them out so now i get out of jail on
monday
i gotta [__] you know take a bus to
[__] everett they told the car i
gotta pay for the car to get towed
it's a [__] nightmare you know
i i don't know what the [__] to do with
my life this is terrible now
the people from la start calling
and they're like this pilot's gonna
happen i didn't hear from them for like
six months
i sent my stuff to the latino laugh
festival
and they actually flew me down oh yeah
for the last
the laugh factory okay to do latino
night on monday night it was
huge in 1996 latino night was huge it
was carlos mancia
george lopez and pablo francisco and
gilbert esquivel
posted it was huge the place was packed
on mondays
the last factory used to be packed on
mondays
so i don't know anybody i come down to
[__] la they put me up at a hotel
in the valley i i take a cab down
another comic drove me i can't remember
and i showcase them at the laugh factory
and i meet a woman named marilyn
martinez
she's cool as [__] i meet jeff garcia
and i meet felipe esparza
i go back to seattle i'm doing my thing
i'm having a great time in seattle doing
the open mics
dodging the cops going to anger
management
you know it was always something i'm
making
you know i so i started i didn't go back
to
boulder so i i started my own sports
betting service
i rented an office above josh wolfe's uh
business me and the girl had broken up
for a while so i lived in the office
that's the office that had a bathroom
just
a a bathroom with a toilet no shower
so i had to join a gym to take showers
but i can't tell you how many nights i
had to take a [__] at like 12 o'clock at
night and the cleaning lady would be in
the building you're not supposed to live
in an office
yeah i was living in a rented office
for 125. they would try to knock on the
door to come in to clean the office i
wouldn't let them i'm working
go away i had an 800 number i'm there
you could call me for football
and i was giving out pics you know i'm
doing it by myself i'm having a great
[__] time
and i remember how many nights i would
just open the window and piss out the
window
and and people would go what the [__] is
going on
up there i would just take my dick out
i'd be all drunk and coked up
and i would just piss out the window let
me tell you something a couple nights i
[__] out that window
i would just put my ass out the window
and just drop two turds out of my ass
and look down and they would fly down it
was like the third floor
i had
i can't tell you how many times
i [__] myself oh god damn dude
i was and now i was friends with a guy
that cooked at that and you can ask
joshua about this
well he's told me you guys have told me
that story about the safe and all you
stole up there
oh dragging it down the steps
oh my god it was [__] crazy
so so uh
i'm living in this office i'm kind of
dating
the crazy chick though that i love this
is still the one
yeah and one day we go to uh she was
into nature
she really liked nature she's a hippie
broad you know
so we go to this [__] river and it's
got like these little caves that you go
into
and the water just runs through you it's
tremendous
at that time we went to see pearl jam at
waterworks
i mean it was just we were [__]
living it up being this fraud
i'm stealing 20s from her every night
driving a [__] blast
you know yeah so we're at this uh we're
at this [__]
reservoir i'll never forget this
whatever this [__] thing is
and we're drinking bottles and james
wine coolers yeah i remember
she's got and she's got a tremendous ass
you know and i'm looking at her ass
she's got a bikini on and i'll never
forget i
we got into some type of argument we
wanted to talk like she wasn't
whatever you want to do it's fine you
know whatever and i'm like i don't know
what this girl's problem is so i
finished the [__] barlows and james
and i'm looking at her [__] ass she's
laying there and i'm looking at a [__]
and i take the bottle and i start
rubbing it on her [__]
with the bikini arm just rubbing it with
the
with the [__] with the bikini on it
rubbing it rubbing it
and i can see her hips are starting to
move she's starting to get hot
[Laughter]
so i pull the bikini over and i take the
bottle
and i start playing with a [__] and the
whole [__] thing
and i start putting the ball into a
[__] right there
you know man we're [__] freaks girl
and i'm working her with the [__]
bottle nice and slow
she's moaning and groaning i'm getting
into it i'm about to take the cuban egg
roll out
i'm yanking myself right i'm about to
whack off and come on the [__] hair
or titties or whatever
i'm working it with this [__] bottle
i'm ready to go i'm excited
and next thing you know i hear
the suction from the bottle she was
about to have a period
so the suction it created a vacuum when
i was
going in and out and all of a sudden it
squirted like the blood started filling
up the bottle
i thought i cut her with the bottle so i
can't see blood so i fainted i just go
backwards
boom and i faint she wakes me up she's
putting ice on me and [__]
she's putting water on me her [__]
i thought i'd cut you she's like no you
just you created a vacuum and you pulled
the
the blood was brown there was period
blood it was [__] brown and [__]
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our next sponsor coors pure living
a balanced lifestyle is important but it
shouldn't stop enjoyment
that's when you reach for coors pure
since it's all organic and has zero
sugar
you can enjoy it without feeling guilty
coors pure
is all about promoting balance and
giving aggressive affirmations
to everyday heroes so whether you got
that run in or
you just got as far as putting on your
running clothes coors pure celebrates
you
course pure it's organic but chill about
it
look i tell you guys every week i found
mine at target
it's my favorite new light beer it's
organic i've always liked light beer
coors it's the best one around and so
many of you have already gone out and
trying to hit me up going hey this thing
is actually really good it is
less calories but the same alcohol
content so
get yourself some coors pure it's coors
pure is the perfect beer to celebrate
the winds
of everyday life so when you want to
enjoy a beer while without the guilt
reach for coors pure it's organic
but chill about it go to coorspure.com
honeydew
to see where you can find coors pure
celebrate responsibly
coors brewing company albany georgia our
next sponsor is expressvpn did you ever
read the fine print that appears when
you start browsing
in incognito mode it says that your
activity might still be visible to your
employer your school or your internet
service provider
how can they even call it incognito to
really stop people from seeing the sites
you visit
you need to do what i do and use
expressvpn think about all the times you
use
wi-fi at a coffee shop a hotel or even
at your parents house
without expressvpn every site you visit
could be logged by the admin of that
network
and that's still true even when you're
in incognito mode
i mean do you really want parents to see
what you've been looking at what's more
your home internet provider i'm talking
comcast at t
whatever they can also see and record
your browsing data and in the us
they're legally allowed to sell that
data to advertisers
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data
and reroutes it through a network of
secure servers so that your private
online activity
stays just that private expressvpn works
on all your devices
and is super easy to use the app
literally has one button you tap
and boom your browsing activity is
secure from prying eyes
so stop letting strangers invade your
online privacy
protect yourself at expressvpn.com
honeydew use my link at expressvpn.com
honeydew to get three extra months free
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n.com
honeydew to learn more now back to the
duke
i'm like this is a [__] nightmare
i never heard anything like that
you jump started a period i jumped out
of that period
man oh my god you're something else man
i love her and i were here and i were
like
so [__] good together but we were so
bad together i know i know
you know she really she really
like encouraged my comedy like i'll
thank her like
nobody knows like the
people that helped me the most of my
comedy was her
and my new wife my wife now 21 years
they have been women always helped me
women were always very good from the
same
so i'm honestly joey i wonder if it does
i mean you lost your mom i lost my i
mean my mom left my dad's gone
and there's just something i say all the
time like the moms
of my friends were always kind to me
like women just have a different nature
the dads were always like you good
all right see you later you know and it
was out the moms were
how you doing let me make you something
to eat what's going on how are we doing
it you know always checking in and then
throughout my life the women have
always been good to me oh almost almost
all of them me too
i'm very grateful to both of them in
fact i talked to the girl from seattle
for the fourth of july
i love that you still keep it we just
spoke on monday
she sent me a picture on the port of her
and her mother
and i looked at it monday morning and i
go can you talk
and we talked a little bit and she said
she's going to write a book it's called
the one chapter is called seattle l.a
and joey diaz
the chapter about us
so uh i was there
and i'll never forget it was june of 96.
and i was there a year already and
there was a rumor going around that
doug stanhope was coming up doug
stanhope was the hottest comic in
america
yeah he had just won the san francisco
comedy competition
and he was the hottest comic in america
i had met doug
in 91 in boulder and again in 92
he had come to boulder as a feature act
where i worked
uh i was the house mc at for tribble and
he came back as a headliner a year later
and i always wondered what happened to
him i really liked him in fact he stayed
at my house
both nights because okay you did boulder
and then you got a hotel in boulder but
then you had a night off
so i would tell the headliners if they
were cool you could stay at my apartment
i got an extra room you know
he stayed with me you know and he was
cool and i lost contact with him i
looked up to him
he was funny as [__] and he was coming
that june
and i couldn't get the feature spot
so that friday i went to see doug
stanhope i'll never forget
it was the greatest live performance i
had ever seen in my life
it was so good that i cancelled my show
on saturday night and cried
you cried i cried because
i knew i would never be as good as doug
stanhope
doug was on a different level in 96. it
was
it was a different style of stand up he
was just book wild
you know talking about that he went to a
strip club and
the chick was so fat there was a thong
in there somewhere and
you know uh i i'll never forget friday
night people were walking out
people were walking and he kept saying
where you going
you didn't hear my tit [__] joke yet
like [__] you
you know it was just it was hilarious he
was
so that sadly i didn't go back down
there i'm not even going down there he
was so good
i'm canceling my [__] gig and i got
to get my life together
i got to get as good as doug stanhl i
mean he inspired me so much
that you know i went back sunday night
and i [__] told him
you know you're [__] great you became
you became a [__] superb
comic i mean i am embarrassed like i
gotta catch up to you
and he's like well listen how about this
catch up to me
and i'll be back here for new year's and
you could open it for me
nice new year's 96 because i just got it
from john fox
i go perfect so i had something to work
for
you know yeah so boom boom boom boom
i'm working i'm doing all this [__]
i'm finally [__] not getting arrested
no more
i'm on probation i'm still going to
anger management
and then something [__] happened
i can't remember what the [__] happened
but i got pulled back into court
like something i gave a hearty way
something happened
and they're like you know uh
i can't [__] remember what the [__]
happened but
i got pulled back into court for like a
review
or something and they were like you're
gonna have to continue
the anger management you're gonna get
additional probate i'm like what the
[__] is going on here you know
and all of a sudden cbs called
it's like november of 96
cbs calls and they're like listen
we want you for this pilot i'm gonna
give you
25 000 bucks like
i've never seen that type of money yes i
know
yeah like what i'm like what are you
talking about
and they're like yeah just come down
we'll put you up
you're gonna shoot for two weeks and
then you'll go back to seattle and i'm
like
whatever i'm walking around like i
didn't say that to nobody
i didn't tell josh wolfe i didn't say
nothing
by this time josh wolf had left he was
he had left in september
i know what happened all right
so josh wolfe leaves in september and i
miss josh
at the time i was living at josh's guest
house
yeah you babysat for him and [__] i
can't i couldn't get over that
yeah we had robbed the safe we did all
that [__]
and he leaves that september
and i get the job of a [__] lifetime
i get a job working for this
telemarketing company
for a new company that's gonna
advertise during football games
for pizza and
you could order pizza from the
television this
wild concept this is 1996.
this is this wild concept of
telemarketing and
they're paying me 20 bucks an hour damn
and bonuses if you sign pizza parlors
because that's what we had to do
we had to sign pizza parlors to
to uh to get into the network and
and that's what the pitch was so if
every pizza parlor you signed you got
like 10 bucks i was knocking them
[__] dead
so i'm there for like a month i'm happy
cbs calls
we're going through with the deal and my
ex picks me up
now i owed her money like 200 bucks or
something
the check was like for 800 bucks or
whatever she's going to cash a check
take the 200 and give me [__] six
bills
right so she's got
like her dog in the front seat and i'm
sitting in the back seat
and we're going to go through the
drive-through and she's going to give
the teller her check and get the money
back
we're at the [__] drive-thru and
she's like you're going to give me 300
hours
and we get into a [__] argument over
the money i'm like
listen i'm not gonna give you [__]
300 bucks i owe you two why would i give
you three
and she's like going back and forth to
me and we'll get into a [__] argument
and she goes you know what [__] you
you're not gonna get nothing now and she
rips up the check
oh [__] and i'm [__] furious like
what the [__] i had people to meet that
night i was getting eight ball
i had all this [__] [__]
and i go over she's like [__] you i'll
go [__] you and she [__]
punches me right in the [__] face and
i grab her hair
and she goes ah that [__] i'm calling
the cops i go [__] you
that's it [__] you we [__] had it and
i run out of the [__] car
and the next thing you know there's cops
everywhere
so what do i do i hired i hide in a
garbage can like a garbage dumpster
outside the tornado restaurant or
something right
so [__] i tell there's a big comic
his name is rico
he's got to be six foot six 300 pounds
he's african-american darker than the
night and he shaved the spider onto his
face
like his beard is a spider
so he's a street guy he's from the bronx
i
call him up from the pay phone before i
jump in the dumpster
i'm like rico listen to me the cops are
looking for me pick me up at this
[__] uh
at the whatever restaurant tornado
restaurant
i'll be in the dumpster i go how long
will it take you because it'll take you
about 20 minutes
you know so i'm hiding in the [__]
dumpster
and i tell them pick me up in front of
the restaurant the dumpster is right
next to it
i could see the cops going by and i
[__] jump in the dumps i'm in a
dumpster there's [__] mice in there
i'm [__] what the [__] is going on
and the next thing you know i look out
the thing and there's rico
200 yards away going like this
and i'm like rico pull over come on over
and the next thing you know cops come
out again so i just hide the
i hide in the [__] dumpster so i'm in
the dumpster
from [__] four in the afternoon it's
got to be
nine o'clock at night no i'm in a
[__] dumpster
i'm pushing roaches away the [__]
mexican kids
throwing garbage in there next to me i'm
like don't throw it on this side throw
it on that side
i give the mexican like five bucks i
don't tell nobody i'm here
so finally about 9 30 i climb out of the
dumpster
and i'm walking through seattle and i
walk past the bush and there's two
[__] cops waiting for me
so they arrest me they take me down
there
they say that you know i pulled the hair
but she admitted to punching me in the
face
the cops saw like i had like a black eye
and they're like you know we'll just
leave it at this or whatever
so [__] they didn't arrest me oh good
they left
they let me go but sure enough i go see
my probation officer the following week
and he puts a warrant off of my arrest
for that didn't [__] stop
for that yeah so i'm like god damn it
but she won't press charges she's like i
punched him in the face it's not fair
so they go all right don't worry about
nothing but probation is on my [__]
ass
it's about december now cbs wants to
know when i'm coming
and i tell him right after new year's
i'm opening up for doug stanhope
i'll have money from doug stanhope i
think
it was 250 to feature then 250 for five
shows new year's eve
fifty dollars a show about seattle
but i didn't give a [__] i was opening
up for doug stanhope new year's
monday so i do the whole three nights
with doug
[__] great i think we added two shows
we did
the countdown and finally on the last
night he goes hey
when you come to l.a to shoot that pilot
just stay there
he goes you would do great in l.a he
goes [__]
stay here man don't leave when you come
to la
he goes you could stay with me i got
bunk beds
at my house you could stay on the bunk
beds
that was like the biggest confidence
booster
i ever had in my life i i didn't know
what to even say to him you know so we
did new years
and uh i had to go to
l.a to shoot for cbs but there was a
hitch
probation wouldn't let me go nah
why because you're going out yeah
so i had to call cbs and tell
them the truth
they contacted an attorney in seattle
and they set up a [__] special
hearing
no way for me to i swear to god it was
like
[__] craziness by this time
the stripper told me she was gonna come
with me
she's like you're not gonna leave me
here by myself i don't know anybody
i'm coming with you that way if you're
gonna be a [__] star i'm like i'm not
gonna be a star i'm just shooting a
[__] pilot
and whatever so but here we had a kick
the probation department wouldn't let me
go
they were like he's not gonna go he's
not able to go he cannot leave the
[__] state
so cbs went in there and fought for me
with my attorney
and finally the judge it was the wildest
thing
the judge had been at the shows no
for new year's no
what a [__] car that's my life
and he goes listen man you're really
funny
wow the joke of the joke about the mall
you didn't do your [__]
all right he goes i'll let you go
to la but do us a favor don't come back
i told you
he goes you've been arrested five times
in one year
he goes just it's like a [__] record
stolen cars
assaults [__] jaywalking you know
this cannot this cannot you know
so
they said you could leave i was in
[__] shock
but they have to continue anger
management classes in los angeles
when you get there and you can [__]
leave
so on january they you know it was a cbs
pilot they wanted me to be down there
but they weren't going to shoot
till [__] in the beginning of march oh
so i once seattle told me to leave i was
like i'm out of here
so on january 20th
me and her with a dog got an rv
we towed her car in the back and we
headed to [__] los angeles
that night january 20th 97 are we in 97
yeah we're in 97. that's when i got here
i got here february 13th 97.
i just beat you i got that january 29th
of 1997 two weeks yeah we got
we got to san francisco and i was going
to do a spot there one night one of the
comics from seattle live in san
francisco
and he goes if you're ever in san
francisco let me know
um you know i'll [__] uh
put you up like whatever you can stay at
my place
so we get to san francisco we
unhitch her car and
we uh [__] you know put the rv on a
corner
and we're in the rv and for some reason
the rv there was something wrong with
the electrical system
so she's like we gotta have the rv toad
i'm like what the [__] i have like 800
bucks for the trip
plus a little money cbs gave me like
they gave me a per diem or some [__]
while they're towing the rv the back
axle fell off no and the rv just landed
on the streets
so we had to [__] get a hotel room
oh man for life
for like three [__] nights and
but i got to do comedy all week in san
francisco i got the
rooster t feathers yeah sam said i love
comedy in san francisco i really like
the punchline
oh it's great i didn't do carbs the guy
was a scumbag
monday night oh really oh but i did like
rooster t
feathers purple onion was it the purple
onion was a great one too
there the purple onion i did that joint
i did something on hate ashbury
and then we finally got that rv back on
uh
we finally got the rv back on like a
saturday
and we headed to la and we pulled in
until a monday january 29th
1997. we pulled in
and i'll never forget it was maybe 8 30
at night we parked on fairfax
between hollywood and sunset
and we took showers and we got the mazda
and we went to acapulco
yeah where the comedy of dojo was
yep yeah i used to do stand up up there
and they would [__] make those
goddamn blended drinks while you were
doing your set
no one could hear you you couldn't hear
[__] yeah
yeah so i i remember still pulling up
monday night
going to acapulco and then from there we
went to the comedy store
and don barris was hosting i
went up there and eddie griffin was on
stage i couldn't believe i was in the
world famous
i know man i know that was the first
time i walked in there
and i knew a guy named james stevens iii
i had opened for him in seattle he was
big time at the store
and i'll never forget that he walked up
to me like at midnight he goes
do you want to go up at the open mic
there was like four people in the
audience i was like are you [__]
serious
because i thought i'd never get a chance
to perform at the comedy store
because in those days if you performed
there it didn't matter in what capacity
you could put
on your resume [__] yeah that would be
great on my resume the comedy's doing
the seattle underground
what are you [__] crazy so he put me
up at the comedy store original room and
i was like
holy [__] i was blown away
i'll never forget just going back that
night for the rv and going
what the [__] we met doug stanhope like
coaching horses
yeah i know yeah it's a great that was a
great rock and roll bar
yes it was and uh i never forget that he
he asked me did you ever get paid for
new year's and i go no
i never got a check and he paid me out
of his pocket
you know so that was great he gave me
500 bucks instead of
250 and i still had the check coming to
me
and uh her and i lived in the rv
we got into an argument i moved in with
stanhope
and i'll never forget that friday i was
going to north hollywood i borrowed stan
hope's car
i was going to north hollywood to apply
for a telemarketing job
and that was the day of the north
hollywood bank
oh yeah i just got here i had just
[__] got here yeah the bank of
america [__] shooting
the bank of america shooting yeah dude
those dudes walked down the street
bulletproof [__] i remember seeing
him finally take the one dude out live
on tv they shot him right through the
head and they wouldn't show that later
in the news
but if you were watching live they
finally took that one dude but that [__]
was hours long
and i lucked out because there was you
were driving into it
i was driving onto the 101 it was tough
to get on there
and i finally went said [__] it somebody
i had in those days there was no waves
or nothing
you had to get the book i had like a
book in the car from going on the road
thomas guide the thomas got made me go
through barham but barham was stuck
so i turned around and i went to a pay
phone and i called the [__] employer
and i go listen there's a lot of traffic
i can't make it up then he goes don't
even worry about it we're closing the
office there's a shooting going on
there's a [__] huge shooting going on
so i was there for that
and then i remember going back and stand
hope saying listen
man when i was at the store last night i
talked to scott day about getting you a
showcase
like are you [__] serious and he goes
yeah
i got him to give you a showcase so he
goes call him up
so i called scott day that monday you
know i still
talked to scott day i didn't know that
we're still friends on facebook he's
like in europe somewhere
africa so
i [__] uh call scott day on a monday
and i go
stanhope preferred me james stevens the
third referred me
carlos mencia referred me i knew carlos
from denver
and scott day goes okay you're on the
list he goes
it's gonna be about six months
i'm like well you know i i had to brag
i'm like i'm here to shoot a pilot for
cbs
so be fine whenever you get to me it'll
be fine
you know it was going to be about six
months i was like [__]
i don't know if i'll be here in six
months you know
and sure enough like a week later on a
friday he calls me he goes
and it was like valentine's weekend or
something like before valentine's week
and he calls me up and he goes do you
want to showcase for mitzy shaw
we've had a couple fallouts it wasn't
even in six weeks
it was like a week i'd go i'll be there
[__] sunday night
and i went down there like my life was
on the line this was
bigger than me going to court just
kidnapping
this is [__] you
i walk in there's the queen herself
mitzi shaw
there's eddie griffin i mean paul mooney
on a sunday night all talking to mitzi
and i had a [__] showcase but i had
that night when i went up
that monday night eddie griffin was
there
and he watched me and i was a fan of
eddie griffin
yeah he had a joke about that uh uh
the guy who invented the telephone
what's his name
alexander graham bell what's the guy he
said the alexander graham bell invented
the telephone cause he did cocaine
and you talk to somebody so that was his
big joke that you know
i saw it on hbo so i went up to him and
i'm like i love that joke about
alexander graham bell with cocaine
so he knew i really knew his material so
it was weird i went in there for the
first showcase
and eddie griffin was there and
i went up to mitzi and i go hi i'm joey
beers i'm number four on the list
and he turned around he goes mitzi keep
your eye on him these are funny
i saw him last week my heart almost
[__] broke i'm like oh my god
and he sat next to mitzi
and he told me when i got off when i got
off mitchie shaw
pulled me towards you and she goes can
you come back next week and
do 10. and i'm like yeah
[__] yeah and then he he came out and
said listen i sat next to her
so nobody would talk to her that's nice
come back next sunday you know and do 10
and i'll be here next sunday was gonna
be my
34th birthday i was going to turn
34 on february 19th
1997 and i'm like this will be
[__] up if i don't become a regular
she tells me no
like this will be [__] heartbreaking
i went down on sunday february 19th
i did my 10 minutes and she [__] made
me a regular
when i got off she goes start calling
for spots tomorrow night
and i immediately broke down like i just
[__] broke down like
all the pain from the divorce all the
pain
from prison my mother i just remember
going in like walking down the stairs
and going into the men's bathroom and
just i didn't want to touch the toilet
with my [__] hands
i got like a towel i closed the toilet
and i just sat there and broke down
i cried my ass off i was now a regular
at the world famous comedy store
when i got to l.a i didn't think i could
do anything with my life
never mind be a [__] regular so by
feb i had gotten ballet january 27th
the 29th 1997
by february 19th not even a month in l.a
i was a regular at the [__] comedy
store so my fate was [__] sealed
right there i knew it i'm like
now i got to work hard because i'm in
the [__] major leagues
that's what i will we'll end right there
that's perfect because now
it just begins that's what's going on
we've done like 10 goddamn episodes and
we're just beginning
all right so wait i have to put this
audio stamp in here so i remember we're
picking up where
where exactly what month and year
exactly what 97
march of 97. march 97 is where we're
gonna pick up next time brother
i love you thank you so much i just want
to make one announcement yeah i was
gonna say promote it all
uh the soprano movie obviously october
1st the trailer
is out and also my weed strain is coming
out
it came out this is yeah it's called
at laughing gas on instagram you know
get on there so you can see
it's going to be sold exclusively at the
ice cream shop
off ventura boulevard oh i'm going to
get that studio city
it's 31 percent and it'll knock you the
[__] out it's joey b
is [__] you know hand-picked
you know they took care of me so trim
the [__]
and trend it's called laughing gas it'll
be exclusively at the ice cream shop
in studio city thank you very much for
having me on brother
i love you you know i do we're gonna
keep going until you wrap it up my man
i love you too man thank you have a
great week great to see you
same man and as always ryan sickler.com
ryan sickler on all social media we'll
talk to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you